invitamos al ourense binner analista
político y consultor internacional
también ex diplomático norteamericano
lawrence bienvenido france24 y le
pregunto tiene este tema de 'tik tok' o
un matiz electoral y es que recordemos
que ya son menos de dos meses para las
presidenciales en las que donald trump
aspira a la reelección
efectivamente el presente principio de
su administración ha colocado a china y
en frente acción con china como un punto
político que cree que está a su favor en
este momento ya en la final parte final
de las elecciones él está aumentando la
presión y está comparando con jobim
quién
acusa como parte de administración de
obama de ser muy flojo con china el
presidente piensa que se puede ser una
ventaja política obvia al mismo tiempo
vicepresidente pipe está también
mostrando que enfrenta ción con china es
parte de su plataforma política bueno
señor algún venir como refleja esta
presión sobre las aplicaciones chinas la
relación actual precisamente entre eeuu
y china
bueno en esta administración esta es una
enfrenta acción muy abierto y muy fuerte
tradicionalmente los eeuu ha tenido
conversaciones muy secretos con china
sobre los problemas hay muchos problemas
hay muchas acusaciones contra china pero
socialmente lo hemos manejado en manera
suave que prefieren los pinos el
presidente camps ha cambiado eso él
prefiere la implicación abierto donde él
puede reclamar en el eso no publica los
problemas que ya tiene con china y luego
declarar victoria cuando él dice que ha
resuelto esos mismos problemas y para
finalizar le pregunto este nuevo cambio
esta nueva negociaciones resolvería las
preocupaciones de seguridad de eeuu al
respecto de que los servidores ya no
estén en china sino dentro del
territorio norteamericano si lo que
sabemos del acuerdo y todavía hay mucho
que confirmar es que por qué
los datos personales de la gente van a
ser manejado y retenido dentro de los
eeuu en eso resolvería por el momento el
problema de que en china al mismo tiempo
como sabemos los datos la privacidad con
los medios sociales es una cuestión muy
difícil mantener dentro de fronteras
entonces siempre hay riesgo con nuestras
aplicaciones